ragazzi questo ci sono i giochi che
sviluppano il quoziente intellettivo
tipo è più mi hanno consigliato anzi
giampiero me l'ha consigliato grazie a
questo jobs sia super su problemi in all
in italiano superluminale è cascato alla
scritta non so se una positività però
figo e amici andare centri volentieri
aprite faremo diventare due sogni realtà
va bene che bello tipo un percorso
psicologico madonna come ragazzi vi
mettete veramente in gioco e niente
caricamento vabbè fammi vedere
ripristinate mi il cervello
ci vorrebbe ben più di un istituto per
fare questo però ok allora praticamente
questo qua è un centro che ti permette
di sviluppare il tuo modo di pensare la
percezione e la realtà grappa quindi
what a svetta in che senso
e quindi anche così diventa grosso nova
mamma mia che viaggio incredibile
no ragazzi non ci crede vagone
bellissimo bicchia no regala sto male la
percezione la realtà quindi si avvicina
una cosa e diventa enorme no ragazzo
malissimo bellissima idea non ho capito
niente di quello che mi sta dicendo però
ho capito che
è una roba per valutarmi qua c'è una
porta ma dietro le 9 gect grandi sponsor
che è lesto e quindi la percezione e la
realtà in che senso
io vorrei passare lì dentro si può non
lo posso portare syz molecola ma vabbè
lasciamo perdere gli avanti a capo vacca
devo pensare in quadri dimensionalmente
non so come si fa però a ok bene era
esattamente la mia prima risposta che
adesso lo riprendo grazie demonio chi si
è inventato cosa c'è nel cervello di
sementa tutta roba un genio no ragazzi
[Musica]
cosa non so neanche leggenda non c'è
stato ha scelto pellicola che non faccia
parte la signora di assistenza ok
stai tranquillo devo mettere di sicuro
bellissimo questo era molto easy let's
go vi si sta in trip andò nel cervello
l'emisfero destro ciò già tutto bello
strizzato però fa niente tribune
pulsanti adesso per ruotare ok che sa
fare la porta che mi metto qua corretto
credo che più grosso di così sia
impossibile ragazzi però il bagoss così
qua ma cosa sto vedendo bellissimo nora
gap e geniale come concetto di gioco
veramente geniale concept o deviato
dall'oriente dice non l'ho capito se
devo fuggire effettivamente da un sogno
o che cosa aspetta che qua dopo salari
sopra questa raisi che sarei se avete
giocato a porta almeno una volta nella
vita
alcune cose sono veramente is it il
western quindi difficile e lanciare le
cose dall'altra parte prova per quello
arriva dopo fa
parco demonio allontanati ok ho dei
problemi ok a lanciarle robe dalle altre
parti perché non è difficile non riesco
a capire questa questione di prospettiva
è difficilissimo ragazzi sin trippa al
cervello cioè non era poi è proprio un
casino è un incrocio ragazzi sapete che
cos'è un incrocio tra de stanley park
ball e anti chamber però questo qua è
solo per i veri intenditori del canale
cioè è difficile da dire cosa no aspetta
non è possibile ha bei penso sia una
roba alla porta vabbè andiamo avanti
va bene il tanto il cervello non ce l'ho
più quindi va bene così
che culo
l'oggetto era questo ora sono aperte
tutte e due pro come apro questa di jos
mio ha forse devo rendere gigantesca
allora gli insegna in modo tale da far
ricoprire tutti e due può essere è una
bella idea questa che ho avuto però non
so quanto possa funzionare vediamo ok
dovrebbe colpirli tutti e due se la
spingo vediamo è vai giù porca vacca non
voglio ritoccarla perché poi ecco poi la
rende più piccola madonna
eccoci no no ti prego non cadere ho già
fatto messo un'ora ma ce l'ho fatta va
bene dove renderla gigante per
schiacciare cosi scout orientation c'è
un'uscita di rega occhio aspetta se
stacco vestimento la scritta uscita non
spetterebbe devo fare delle robe con gli
spiragli che vedo madonna che casino sto
gioco ma ha fatto benissimo a si
sfondava va bene grazie
come si fa me ne vado via non so neanche
dove sto andando ma fa niente war crisba
i professori entrato nei meandri del
gioco fighissimo vado verso l'uscita
sto andando
siamo qui non credo ma chi può il
caricamento al contrario ragazzi
bellissimo se finisco sto gioco vado a
vomitare praticamente le 3 del mattino
non ho mai visto questo orario va bene
fammi capire come incasinarmi il
cervello ancora un po a guarda che ci ho
proprio voglia ragazzi dove stiamo
finendo santo iddio dove stia infine
what he un hotel
sto tirando le robe antincendio mi
chiamo con disastro quindi la possiamo
smettere di mettere la musica che mi dà
fastidio è proprio la musica minimi
inquieta what the fuck
macché va beh no ragazze vi giuro due
chicche ma cosa ma questo vedo la gamma
che cosa cosa stiamo parlando
madonna
no vabbè minchia o basta non sto capendo
più niente vi chiede disagio non si
capisce nulla
gli ho tirato tutte le cose antincendio
ma non so cosa serve
no ragazzi guardate che qualche
guardaroba che gli è venuto in mente di
fare sta roba qui uscita qua a destra ok
uscita sempre qua destra va bene sempre
a destra con l'ultimo andare a destra va
bene a posto forse la deve piazzare al
posto di un'insegna così diventano
uscita chiedo per un amico ce l'ho fatta
sono riuscito a passare facendo dei
casini che non vi dico lega c'è
veramente ho fatto un disastro
amen my name sai vedo talking perche la
panne pink grazie lo sa di essere
speciale tesoro demonio cosa vedo ma è
spuntato un cubo davvero va bene ecco
questo dopo questo questo mi ha sorpreso
un sacco è sbloccata la porta dietro
vado perché si è fermata la musica
quando nei giochi anche non horror la
musica si ferma a caso mikado un più
sotto non c'è un vero motivo però
dovrebbe fermarsi da musiche al caso
dovrebbe essere illegale altra cosa
my name stop 20 sale anche il dottor
seniga imprevisti più aq sacrosanto il
dio è un alfiere pad rischi ed è
localizzata
lui sì vorrei muovermi for words solo
che non so come salire su un cubo lì in
riga o anch'io ho cho bene ormai ragazzi
c'è ormai importante nell'ottica di non
capirsi una sega è tutto perfetto
ok hai proprio si è creato uno spazio
parco demonio c'è comando ma come si fa
a programmare una roba del genere
ragazzi ma dalla serie con di voi
programmatori come si fanno ste cose
è allucinante sta porta e minimal e
super minimal e veramente un incrocio
tra de stanley per ball e anti chamber
giuro su dio la proporzione pazzesca
[Musica]
attivarmi degli ascensori treatment ari
ancora vi devo fare perfetto perfetto
barone la luna cos'è sta roba
c'è l'uscita è una porta d'uscita la
creo io aia perfetto dai inventiva
dritta arcore olio
eccoci no non è entrato nome tutto aiuto
ecco lo ha posto alla madonna raia che
trip belli il sì moto sono belli in
gioco della vita pazzesco bellissimo
sequestro al giorno che stiamo per
andare a fare le cose serie abbiamo
preso un ascensore ragazzi non vedo
l'ora di ragazzi in questo era il primo
episodio di super limin al perché a
quanto pare ce ne devono essere altri
perché è bello lungo come gioco ma non
vedo l'ora di farli 4 del mattino
vedremo nei prossimi tod's cosa ci
capiamo fuori bellissimo che il gioco
pazzesco dai ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto piaciute con la bellissima
campanellina prima né ragionati sui noi
vi dove escono e noi come sempre ragazzi
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video per
ragazzi
[Musica]